(man) THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
FIVE POWERFUL, SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
LAST SEASON, THE SHARKS
INVESTED OVER $5 MILLION
IN PRODUCTS AND BUSINESSES.
THIS SEASON,
THE STAKES ARE EVEN HIGHER
AND THE SHARKS ARE EVEN RICHER.
WHAT IF I OFFERED YOU
$1.25 MILLION?
THE SHARKS ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
OH!
IT'LL KICK YOU IN THE THROAT
A LITTLE BIT.
UGH.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
MARK, YOU'RE SAYING,
"SCREW THE OTHER SHARKS."
YEP.
I'VE NEVER SEEN GREED LIKE THAT.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE GREED.
BUT FIRST THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
YOU'RE NOT THAT CRAZY.
(woman) NONE OF YOU KNOW
THE INDUSTRY.
BUT I KNOW HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
AND TONIGHT‐‐MARK CUBAN.
THIS SELF‐MADE BILLIONAIRE
STARTED OUT AS A PAPERBOY,
AND NOW IS A MEDIA MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
(man) FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS JASON LUCASH
AND MICHAEL SZYMCZAK
WITH A CREATIVE
NEW TECHNOLOGY BUSINESS.
♪♪♪
I'M JASON...
AND I'M MIKE,
AND OUR COMPANY IS OrigAudio.
WE LOVE TO TRAVEL.
WE'RE TOTAL TRAVEL JUNKIES
AND HAVE BEEN ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
AND WE ALSO LOVE MUSIC.
AND THE GREAT THING IS,
OUR COMPANY COMBINES BOTH.
WE USE CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY
TO MAKE PORTABLE AUDIO PRODUCTS
THAT ARE PERFECT
FOR TAKING YOUR MUSIC ON THE GO.
WE'VE BEEN FRIENDS
SINCE JUST AFTER COLLEGE,
AND A YEAR AGO
WE BECAME BUSINESS PARTNERS.
WE DON'T TAKE OURSELVES
TOO SERIOUSLY,
BUT WE TAKE OUR BUSINESS
VERY SERIOUSLY.
♪♪♪
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
OUT OF MY HOUSE.
WE'RE JUST STARTING OUT,
SO MONEY'S A LITTLE TIGHT.
GETTING A DEAL FROM THE SHARKS
WOULD BE SO AWESOME.
WE'RE YOUNG
AND WE'RE JUST STARTING OUT.
THEIR HELP AND FUNDING
COULD TAKE OUR BUSINESS
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS JASON LUCASH...
AND MY NAME IS
MIKE SZYMCZAK,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS OrigAudio.
WE ARE SEEKING
A $150,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 15% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
NOBODY LIKES TO TRAVEL
WITH BIG, BULKY SPEAKERS
IN THEIR SUITCASE.
BY THE TIME
YOU PACK THEM IN THERE,
YOU DON'T HAVE ROOM
FOR A PAIR OF SOCKS
OR LET ALONE
YOUR FAVORITE SWIMSUIT.
AW.
(sharks laugh)
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THESE KINDS OF SACRIFICES
IN ORDER TO TAKE THEIR MUSIC
ON THE ROAD WITH THEM,
AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE CREATED OrigAudio
AND WE ARE REVOLUTIONIZING
THE PORTABLE SPEAKER INDUSTRY.
OUR LATEST INVENTION
IS CALLED THE ROCK‐IT.
UTILIZING VIBRATION
TECHNOLOGY,
WE CAN TURN ANYTHING‐‐
YES, ANYTHING‐‐INTO A SPEAKER.
MAYBE YOU WANNA HAVE
A LITTLE ROCK‐IT IN THE MORNING.
(rock music playing)
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
(music stops)
IT'S ACTUALLY
VIBRATION TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S A TRANSDUCER,
AND WHATEVER IT STICKS TO...
(music resumes)
IT TURNS THAT INTO A SPEAKER
BY UTILIZING SOUND MOVEMENT.
(music stops)
MAYBE YOU WANNA ROCK‐IT
WHEN YOU'RE WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
(music resumes)
(music stops)
OR MAYBE YOU JUST WANT TO
REDUCE, REUSE, AND ROCK‐IT.
(music resumes)
(music stops)
WOW.
THE BEST THING
WE'VE EVER HEARD IT ON‐‐
UPSIDE‐DOWN FISHING BOAT
IN PHOENIX, ARIZONA. WE PUT IT
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE. TURNED
THE WHOLE BOAT INTO A SPEAKER.
(laughs)
WE'RE NOT EVEN GONNA ASK
HOW YOU KNEW THAT.
WE'VE‐‐
WE'VE TRIED EVERYTHING.
(laughs)
SO THIS IS OUR FIRST PRODUCT
THAT WE CAME TO MARKET WITH‐‐
FOLDING SPEAKERS‐‐
HENCE THE NAME OrigAudio‐‐
THE ORIGAMI OF AUDIO.
THEY COME FLAT LIKE SO. THEY'RE
MADE FROM RECYCLED MATERIAL.
THOSE ARE SPEAKERS?
YES. YOU FOLD THEM TOGETHER.
AND THE COOL THING ABOUT THEM,
THEY'RE ECO‐FRIENDLY.
THEY'RE POWERED OFF YOUR iPod.
NO BATTERIES WHATSOEVER.
HOW DO THEY SOUND?
FOR THEIR SIZE,
THEY'RE QUITE GOOD.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR ONE YEAR,
AND WE HAVE $750,000
IN SALES.
WHOA.
SO, JASON, IF I BROKE UP
THAT $750,000, WOULD IT COME
FROM THAT DEVICE?
$500,000 ARE FROM
OUR FIRST PRODUCT,
THOSE FOLD‐AND‐PLAY
RECYCLED SPEAKERS.
THE OTHER $250,000 HAVE COME
FROM THE ROCK‐IT.
HOW MUCH DOES THAT POCKET AUDIO
PIECE THAT YOU INITIALLY HAD,
HOW MUCH DOES
THAT RETAIL FOR?
$49.99.
WHY DO YOU NEED THE MONEY?
UH, WE NEED THE MONEY
FOR MORE EMPLOYEES,
PRODUCT FULFILLMENT,
UM, ACCOUNTING FEES.
RIGHT NOW, ALL OF OUR ORDERS
FOR SOMEONE
WHO ORDERED FROM OUR WEB SITE
ARE SHIPPED FROM MIKE'S GARAGE.
SO, JASON, THE $750,000
OVER THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
RIGHT.
AND HOW DID YOU GET THAT?
THROUGH RETAIL?
OUR PRODUCT'S SOLD IN OVER
500 STORES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND WE'RE IN SOME OF
THE LARGEST HOME GOODS STORES,
SOME OF THE LARGEST
TEEN STORES,
AND WE DO A LOT
OF BUSINESS ONLINE.
$750,000. WHAT DID YOU NET?
OUR NET PROFIT
WAS $150,000.
(Mark) ON THE ROCK‐IT?
(Barbara) DID YOU TAKE SALARIES?
DID EITHER OF YOU TAKE SALARIES?
NO, WE HAVEN'T TAKEN A DIME
OUT OF THE COMPANY AS OF YET.
SO YOU DIDN'T NET THAT BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T PAY YOURSELVES YET.
ON THE ROCK‐IT‐‐
IS IT YOUR TECHNOLOGY,
OR DID YOU LICENSE IT?
THE ROCK‐IT IS ACTUALLY, UM,
IT'S PATENTED IN CHINA,
UM, THROUGH OUR FACTORY.
WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE DISTRIBUTOR
AGREEMENT WITH OUR FACTORY.
YOU HAVE A LICENSE RIGHT NOW
FROM A FACTORY IN CHINA.
CORRECT.
SO YOU DON'T MAKE THE PRODUCT,
YOU DISTRIBUTE IT.
WE DISTRIBUTE IT,
BUT WE ALSO AID
IN A LOT
OF THE MANUFACTURING.
BUT‐‐BUT WHAT IS THAT AGREEMENT
WITH THAT LICENSE‐‐
HOW LONG
DOES THAT LICENSE LAST?
FIVE YEARS.
SO FIVE YEARS, YOU WOULD HAVE TO
RENEW THAT LICENSE WITH THEM.
CORRECT.
HOW MUCH CASH
DO GUYS HAVE IN THERE?
WE'VE PUT IN $40,000,
INCLUDING A, UH,
$10,000 INVESTMENT,
ACTUALLY, FROM MY MOM,
WHICH I THINK
YOU CAN APPRECIATE AS WELL.
YAY, MOM!
(laughs)
(O'Leary) THERE'S A LOT OF GUYS
IN PORTABLE AUDIO.
THERE'S A LOT
OF DEVICES SIMILAR.
RIGHT.
BUT YOU'VE PUT A VALUE
OF A MILLION DOLLARS
ON YOUR BUSINESS,
YOU DON'T EVEN PAY YOURSELVES.
LET'S GET SERIOUS HERE. WHY
IS IT WORTH A MILLION DOLLARS?
WE'VE HAD $750,000 IN SALES
IN ONE YEAR, RIGHT?
YEAH, BUT IF IT'S
NOT PROFITABLE‐‐
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT A BUSINESS
IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH MONEY‐‐
(Daymond) IT'S ACTUALLY
IN THE NEGATIVE.
$150,000 PROFIT
FROM A $40,000 INVESTMENT.
YEAH, BUT YOU CAN'T
COUNT THAT.
IF YOU DON'T PAY YOURSELF,
YOU'RE NOT MAKING ANY MONEY.
YEAH, WE'RE AT THE POINT
WHERE WE WANT TO START
PAYING OURSELVES, AND‐‐
I WOULD THINK YOU WERE AT
THE POINT WHERE YOU WANNA EAT.
(laughs)
BUT THIS IS STILL
A LICENSE FROM A FACTORY.
YES.
WHY, IF THIS TAKES OFF,
AND THEY CAN START MANUFACTURING
FOR EVERYBODY‐‐
IT'S THEIR LICENSE ANYWAY,
IT'S THEIR PROPERTY‐‐
WHY WOULDN'T THEY DO THAT?
YOU KNOW, IT'S A REALLY,
REALLY STRONG RELATIONSHIP
THAT WE STARTED
BEFORE OrigAudio‐‐
THEY'LL THROW YOU UNDER A BUS
IN TWO SECONDS FOR MORE MONEY.
YOU KNOW, GUYS, I THINK‐‐I THINK
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS DEAL IS,
IT'S IN
A VERY COMPETITIVE SPACE.
CONSUMER ELECTRONICS
IS FIGHTING FOR SHELF SPACE.
THERE'S ALWAYS
THE NEXT NEW, HOT ITEM.
THE VALUE YOU WANT FOR YOUR
BUSINESS, THE MILLION DOLLARS
ON SOMETHING
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY MONEY‐‐
LET'S BE SERIOUS‐‐
IS A PROBLEM.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
DO YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
THIS PRODUCT WHEN YOU SELL IT?
BECAUSE I WAS JUST LOOKING AT
THE BOX, AND I'M NOT QUITE SURE
I'D HAVE THE PATIENCE
TO READ IT AND GET HOW IT WORKS.
ONCE YOU SHOW IT,
IT COMES TO LIFE.
PART OF THE MONEY THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR FROM AN INVESTMENT,
WE WANT TO PUT POINT‐OF‐SALE
IN STORES TO HELP SELL PRODUCT.
THE BIGGEST SELLING CHANNEL
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS,
WE SELL A LOT
ON TELEVISION.
HOW DO YOU SELL
ON TELEVISION?
QVC IS ONE OF OUR LARGEST,
LARGEST RETAILERS.
YOU'VE BEEN ON QVC?
YES.
WERE YOU GONNA WAIT TILL
EVERYBODY WAS OUT
TO TELL US THAT?
WE WERE GONNA WAIT
TILL KEVIN WAS OUT.
WELL, WHAT A RELIEF.
TWO SIDES TO EVERYTHING,
RIGHT?
(Daymond) BOY IS GENIUS.
JASON, HOW DID YOU GET
ON QVC?
I MEAN, THIS STORY
GETS MORE AND MORE AMAZING.
THEY ACTUALLY SAW US.
WE WERE DEMONSTRATING
THE ROCK‐IT AT THE TRADE SHOW.
THEY ASKED YOU
TO COME ON QVC?
YEAH, WHERE IT'S ACTUALLY
USUALLY THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I LIKE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING
AND I LIKE THAT THE FACT
THAT YOU GUYS ARE DEEP INTO
THE TECHNOLOGY AND RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU HAVE TO STAY
AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
YES.
AND I'M A LITTLE BIT
O'LEARIOUS OF, UM...
(laughter)
YOUR VALUATION.
AND SO THAT CONCERNS ME.
AND, UM, YOU GUYS ARE SMART,
SO I'M SURE YOU CAME IN
READY AND WILLING
TO NEGOTIATE.
I WANT YOU TO COME BACK TO ME
WITH A PERCENTAGE THAT SAYS,
YOU KNOW WHAT? FOR YOUR 150K,
LET'S JUST GO TO WORK.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO EVEN
TALK TO THESE GUYS ANYMORE.
IF YOU COME BACK TO ME WITH
A NUMBER, I'LL SAY YES OR NO,
AND THEN YOU CAN TALK TO THEM.
I DON'T WANT TO TURN THIS
INTO A NEGOTIATION
WITH THE OTHER SHARKS.
HOW DOES THIS SOUND‐‐
IF YOU JUST WANNA DEAL
WITH THEM AND NOT ME,
THEN I'LL JUST BOW OUT
RIGHT NOW.
WOW.
$150,000, TELL ME THE PERCENT,
I'LL SAY YES OR NO,
AND IF I SAY YES,
WE'RE DONE, RIGHT?
OR GO DEAL WITH THEM 'CAUSE I
DON'T WANNA PLAY ALL THE GAMES‐‐
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
YOU'RE' ASKING HIM‐‐YOU'RE
ASKING HIM TO TAKE THAT OPTION
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW
AND IGNORE US.
YEP. YEP.
YOU'RE NOT A VERY NICE GUY.
YEP.
IT'S YOUR GAME TO PLAY, GUYS.
MARK, YOU'RE SAYING
DEAL WITH ME,
SCREW THE OTHER SHARKS,
THROW THEM UNDER THE BUS
BECAUSE I AM THE BEST AND MOST
WONDERFUL HUMAN BEING
BECAUSE I THROW CHAIRS
AT A BASKETBALL GAME.
NO, ACTUALLY, I'VE NEVER THROWN
A CHAIR AT A BASKETBALL GAME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME
BEING WONDERFUL.
NO, NO, I HAVE THAT TITLE,
THANK YOU.
IT'S ABOUT MAKING
A BUSINESS DECISION, RIGHT?
I'M GONNA PUT A CLOCK. YOU'VE
GOT A 24‐SECOND SHOT CLOCK.
YOU COME BACK TO ME
WITH A NUMBER.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW WHAT? IF
THERE'S A SHOT CLOCK VIOLATION,
YOU GUYS CAN DEAL
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE.
♪♪♪
(man) ONE SHARK IS OUT,
AND MARK CUBAN HAS ASKED
JASON AND MIKE
TO COME BACK TO HIM
WITH A BETTER OFFER
AND STOP NEGOTIATING
WITH THE OTHER SHARKS.
YOU KNOW, I WANT IN
ON THIS DEAL.
I THINK THE WAY
I SEE THINGS DEVELOPING,
IT'S A‐‐IT'S A MARK CUBAN
OR THE REST OF THE SHARKS.
I‐I DON'T LIKE BULLIES.
AND, YOU KNOW,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, MR. CUBAN,
THAT'S KIND OF A BULLY,
"LOOK AT ME, I'M THE BIG GUY
ON THE SCHOOLYARD" TACTIC.
AND I DON'T LIKE
TO PLAY THAT WAY.
LIKE I SAID, GUYS,
YOU GOTTA PAY TO PLAY.
THERE'S TENSION IN THIS ROOM.
I CAN FEEL IT.
LISTEN, GUYS. $300,000
FOR 100% OF THE COMPANY.
YOU'RE NOT THAT CRAZY.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER
OF $150,000
FOR 25% OF YOUR BUSINESS.
YOU CAME IN HERE
LOOKING FOR $150,000
FOR 15%.
(Jason) CORRECT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 15%.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA NEED
MORE MONEY DOWN THE ROAD.
AND I'M GONNA BE THERE.
I LOVE THIS STORY.
I'LL INVEST IN YOU GUYS.
BUT WHAT I'LL ALSO BRING
TO THE TABLE IS
MY PARTNER IN NEW YORK
WHO OWNS "AS SEEN ON TV."
ON A TYPICAL COMMERCIAL,
HE TYPICALLY GENERATES
OVER $50 MILLION IN SALES.
OKAY, SO THREE DEALS
AND A 24‐SECOND CLOCK
ON THE TABLE.
NO, THE 24‐SECOND CLOCK EXPIRED
BECAUSE I SAID THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE 24‐SECOND CLOCK‐‐
SO HANG ON. YOU'RE OUT, CUBAN?
I'M OUT.
(O'Leary) I'M GONNA SUMMARIZE
THESE DEALS.
THE FIRST OFFER FROM ROBERT IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU CAME IN FOR‐‐
$150,000 FOR 15%.
BARBARA HAS OFFERED YOU
$150,000 FOR 25%.
AND ALSO THAT I HAVE
A PERFECT PARTNER FOR YOU
TO MAKE THIS A SLAM DUNK.
(O'Leary) DAYMOND WANTS
100% OF YOUR BUSINESS
FOR $300,000 CASH TO YOU.
AND MARK WANTS TO BULLY.
OH, BUT HANG ON. HE'S OUT.
(chuckles)
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
♪♪♪
YEAH, WE'RE GONNA TAKE
OUR TIME‐OUT
AND GO TALK ABOUT IT.
(laughs)
"HI, I'M MARK CUBAN.
I'M A BULLY. LOOK AT ME."
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT, MARK?
CUBAN‐‐THAT WAS CRAZY.
I KNOW. I KNOW.
DAYMOND'S IS INSANE.
YEAH, DON'T DEAL WITH HIM.
100% FOR $300,000? BARBARA ASKED
FOR PROOF OF PROFITS.
YOU CAN PARTNER WITH SOMEONE‐‐
"AS SEEN ON TV."
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO DO?
HEY, MARK, WHEN I BECOME
A BILLIONAIRE,
CAN I NEGOTIATE WITH PEOPLE
LIKE THAT?
CAN I SAY, "HEY, WHY DON'T YOU
GUYS JUST TELL ME WHAT YOU WANT?
OTHERWISE, 24‐SECOND CLOCK
IS GONE."
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE LIKE THAT DEAL OF, UH,
UNCLE ROB BEING
IN OUR BACK POCKET.
SO, UH, LET'S MAKE MAGIC
HAPPEN, ROB.
ALL RIGHT. GREAT, GUYS.
WOW. CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
DAMN!
GOOD JOB, GUYS,
I LOVED IT. I LOVED IT.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
(Jason) THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAN! I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
(Mark) CONGRATULATIONS.
(Robert) THANKS, GUYS. YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL.
(Jason) THANK YOU, MARK.
(Barbara) YOU KNOW,
I'M DISAPPOINTED, GUYS.
IN THE END, IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
THE MONEY, ISN'T IT?
(Robert) YOU GUYS MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
THANK YOU.
WE NEVER KNOW WHICH WAY
IT'S GONNA GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS ISN'T THE ROSE GARDEN.
IT'S THE SHARK TANK.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? SOMETIMES
YOU GOTTA TAKE THE BITE
AND SOMETIMES YOU'RE THE CHUM.
♪♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS JOHNSON BAILEY
WITH A NEW TWIST
ON A FAMILIAR PRODUCT.
♪♪♪
HEY, GUYS,
MY NAME'S JOHNSON BAILEY.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR $50,000.
IN EXCHANGE, I'M WILLING
TO GIVE YOU 25% OF MY COMPANY.
A FEW YEARS AGO,
I WAS GONNA HAVE THE GUYS COME
OVER TO WATCH A FOOTBALL GAME,
BUT MY PLACE STUNK.
I HAD DIRTY CLOTHES,
OLD CHINESE FOOD.
SO I TRIED TO COME UP
WITH AN IDEA
THAT COULD MAKE THE HOUSE
SMELL GOOD BUT ALSO MANLY.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS, THOUGH,
WAS THAT ALL I HAD
WAS, LIKE, A VANILLA LAVENDER
FROUFROU SCENTED CANDLE.
YOU KNOW,
THAT WASN'T GONNA WORK.
AND THAT'S WHEN I CAME UP
WITH THE IDEA
THAT WOULD REVOLUTIONIZE
THE CANDLE INDUSTRY FOREVER.
MAY I PRESENT TO YOU
THE ORIGINAL MAN CANDLE!
(laughs)
WE'RE GOT POT ROAST,
WE'VE GOT GOLF COURSE,
BARBECUE, FOOTBALL,
DRAFT BEER, POPCORN‐‐
AWESOME MANLY FRAGRANCES.
OR SAY THERE'S SOMEONE
IN YOUR HOUSE
YOU REALLY DON'T WANT
TO HANG AROUND TOO LONG.
THE WORKING TITLE FOR THIS
CANDLE WAS "MOOCH BE GONE"
OR "MOTHER‐IN‐LAW BE GONE,"
BUT I DECIDED TO GO WITH
A TAMER CANDLE‐‐THE FART CANDLE.
(sharks laugh)
YOU JUST LIGHT THAT CANDLE.
20 MINUTES,
I GUARANTEE YOU THEY'RE GONE.
(man) I BET.
(sharks laugh)
YOU CAN'T REALLY APPRECIATE
A MAN CANDLE, THOUGH,
JUST BY LOOKING AT IT.
YOU GOTTA SMELL IT.
SO I BROUGHT SOME FOR YOU TODAY.
FOR YOU‐‐NEW CAR.
GIVE BARBARA THE FART.
DON'T GIVE ME THAT ONE.
(chuckles) BEACH BABE FOR YOU.
FREEDOM‐‐ALL‐AMERICAN CANDLE.
(Robert) OH, WOW.
THE BACON‐SCENTED CANDLE.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
HOW ABOUT A BASKETBALL‐SCENTED
CANDLE? (laughs) IMAGINE THAT.
IMAGINE THAT, HUH?
♪♪♪
(laughs)
(Robert) SMELL THAT. NEW CAR.
IT SMELLS LIKE A NEW CAR.
(laughs)
I DO HAVE
MY NUMBER ONE‐SELLER HERE
IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO TRY IT‐‐
THE INFAMOUS
FART‐SCENTED CANDLE.
YES, I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT.
THERE YOU ARE.
OH!
(laughs)
(laughs) OH, HO!
LET ME SMELL. LET ME SMELL.
OH, LET ME TRY THAT.
LET ME SMELL THAT.
THAT IS OUR NUMBER ONE‐SELLER,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
DOES IT GET WORSE WHEN IT BURNS?
UM, YOU KNOW, IT GETS, UM...
OH! (laughs)
(man) IT GETS LOUDER.
IT JUST GETS LOUDER.
IT'S‐‐IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
A FRAGRANCE GETTING LOUDER,
BUT IT DOES.
UGH.
IT'LL KICK YOU IN THE THROAT
A LITTLE BIT.
(bell dings)
TELL US ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
UM, THEY RETAIL $10 TO $12.
WE'VE GOT ROUGHLY
AROUND 400 STORES RIGHT NOW
THAT CARRY THE PRODUCT
FROM COAST TO COAST.
UM, YEAH, MOM‐AND‐POP SHOPS,
WE'VE GOT SOME KINDA HIGHER END,
MORE RECOGNIZABLE, UM,
GIFT STORES‐‐SOME CARD
AND GIFT STORES THAT CARRY 'EM.
IT'S JUST A, YOU KNOW,
A FUN PRODUCT TO‐‐
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
THE SALES? WE DID
$53,000, ROUGHLY, LAST YEAR,
UM, THIS YEAR WE'RE GOING TO‐‐
$53,000 OR UNITS?
$53,000 IN SALES.
NOW, JOHNSON, YOU CAN'T EAT
THIS WAX. HOW DO YOU LIVE?
WELL, MY WIFE WORKS
FULL‐TIME, SO...
AND YOU DON'T WORK,
JUST DO CANDLES?
I DO CANDLES, YEAH.
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING.
YOU GOT A SHOT HERE, RIGHT?
DON'T LET THESE GUYS
DRAG YOU DOWN.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
I'M IN‐‐STILL IN COLLEGE.
I CAME UP WITH THIS, UM,
AS MY BUSINESS PLAN
FOR MY ENTREPRENEURSHIP CLASS.
DID YOU PUT ANY MONEY INTO THIS,
YOU AND YOUR WIFE?
WE HAVE. WE'VE PUT
RIGHT AROUND $40,000 INTO IT.
WHERE DO YOU MAKE THEM?
HOW ARE YOU MANUFACTURING THEM?
UM, I HANDPOUR THEM,
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
YOU WHAT?
YOU HANDPOUR 'EM?
I HANDPOUR THEM.
HE'S HANDPOURING EACH CANDLE
HIMSELF.
MM.
JOHNSON, I GOTTA ASK YOU, WHY?
I'M SITTING HERE THINKING,
HAS ANYBODY EVER TOLD YOU
THIS WAS A GOOD IDEA?
DON'T KILL HIM YET, ROBERT.
IT'S ACTUALLY‐‐
NO, YOU‐‐
NO, I WAS JUST WONDERING, MARK,
HAS‐‐HAS HE GOTTEN
IN FRONT OF AN INVESTOR OR‐‐
WHAT HE'S GOTTEN‐‐
MORE IMPORTANTLY,
HE'S GOTTEN
IN FRONT OF CUSTOMERS.
SO YOU'VE GOT 'EM
IN THESE GIFT SHOPS
AND YOU'VE GOT 'EM
IN THE MOM‐AND‐POP SHOPS.
YOU KNOW, WHAT‐‐WHAT IS
THE NORMAL REORDER PATTERN?
WELL, LIKE, FOR INSTANCE,
OUR‐‐OUR HIGH END, UM,
CARD AND GIFT CHAINS
THAT CARRY THE PRODUCT,
A LOT OF THOSE STORES,
YOU KNOW,
WE SEE SIX TO SEVEN REORDERS
A YEAR.
A REORDER SIX, SEVEN TIMES
A YEAR IS NOT A LOT.
YEAH. I MEAN, THAT'S NOTHING.
JOHNSON,
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT PUTTING WAX IN A CAN
AND SELLING IT.
THIS FALLS INTO
A CATEGORY OF A PRODUCT
I CALL "CRAP FOR TOURISTS,"
AND I'M NOT SAYING IT'S BAD.
THE PET ROCK FELL INTO THAT
AND MADE SOMEBODY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS
A PET ROCK.
I THINK
IT'S AN INTERESTING TCHOTCHKE.
I CAN'T REALLY INVEST IN IT,
SO I'M OUT.
I THINK YOUR BEST GIMMICK THERE
IS THE FART CANDLE.
BUT, UM, THE BUSINESS
IS JUST NOT BIG ENOUGH.
I'M OUT.
THIS IS A SITUATION‐‐
I REALLY CALL IT, UM,
A VITAMIN‐C DEFICIENCY...
'CAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE CASH,
CREDIT, OR ENOUGH CUSTOMERS.
I'M OUT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THIS WILL MAKE
ANY MONEY. I'M OUT.
WHO'S LEFT? JUST ME?
YOU'RE KILLING ME, JOHNSON.
ON‐‐ON ONE SIDE, I CAN SEE
THE ENTREPRENEURIAL VISION.
I‐I SEE THE ATTACK DOG IN YOU
THAT JUST LOVES THIS
AND IS READY TO RUN WITH IT.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE,
YOU'RE A SINGLE PRODUCT,
AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S REALLY A FULL COMPANY.
AND BECAUSE I CAN'T VISUALIZE IT
AS A FULL COMPANY,
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANKS, GUYS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD LUCK.
♪♪♪
HE WAS MISSING ONE FLAVOR THAT
WOULD'VE GOT ME INTERESTED‐‐
MONEY. THE SMELL OF MONEY.
(sharks laugh)
I THINK THE, YOU KNOW, SMELLING
THE FART CANDLE TOO LONG
MIGHT'VE CLOUDED THEIR JUDGMENT
A LITTLE BIT, MIGHT'VE, UM,
GAVE THEM A LITTLE, UM,
DEFICIENCY OF SOME TYPE.
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS JULIE GOLDMAN
WITH A BUSINESS CAPITALIZING ON
THE LUCRATIVE WEDDING INDUSTRY.
HELLO,
MY NAME IS JULIE GOLDMAN.
I AM THE FOUNDER AND C. E. O.
OF THE ORIGINAL RUNNER COMPANY.
I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT MY BUSINESS
AND TO REQUEST
A $250,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 15% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT I PERFECT
LIFE'S GRAND ENTRANCES,
AND I DO THIS
BECAUSE I'VE CREATED
THE WORLD'S FIRST
NON‐SLIP FABRIC AISLE RUNNERS
FOR WEDDINGS
AND SPECIAL EVENTS.
WHEN I WAS PLANNING MY WEDDING,
I NEEDED AN AISLE RUNNER
TO COVER THE ABSOLUTELY HIDEOUS
CARPETING IN THE CEREMONY VENUE.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE REALLY EASY.
I WOULD JUST GO DOWN
TO MY LOCAL STORE
AND PICK UP AN AISLE RUNNER.
BUT WHEN I GOT THERE,
IT WAS ACTUALLY MORE LIKE
GOING TO A SUPERMARKET
BECAUSE MY CHOICES WERE
EITHER PAPER OR PLASTIC.
AND NEITHER OF THESE
ARE REALLY GREAT OPTIONS
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE WEARING
STILETTO HEELS,
IT'S GONNA TEAR, RIP, BUNCH,
AND THERE GO
YOUR WEDDING PICTURES.
THERE WAS ACTUALLY
NOTHING ELSE ON THE MARKET
THAT WAS SAFE AND BEAUTIFUL.
I MADE MY OWN AISLE RUNNER,
AND THE ORIGINAL RUNNER COMPANY
WAS BORN.
MY VERY LOYAL WHOLESALE
AND CELEBRITY CLIENTELE
HAS RESULTED IN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF MY AISLE RUNNERS
BEING SOLD WORLDWIDE
THROUGH MY WEB SITE ALONE.
BUT THAT'S GONNA CHANGE TODAY
BECAUSE I'M PRESENTING TO YOU
THE WALK‐SAFE AISLE RUNNER.
THIS IS OUR 50‐FOOT
NON‐SLIP FABRIC AISLE RUNNER
MASS PRODUCED AND SOLD IN RETAIL
STORES FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
AND THROUGH THOUSANDS
OF ONLINE WEDDING WEB SITES.
(man speaks indistinctly)
THEY'RE JUST
PLAIN WHITE RUNNERS,
WHICH IS THE MOST POPULAR
AISLE RUNNER SOLD IN THE WORLD.
IN ADDITION, I'M INTRODUCING
FOR THE FIRST TIME
OUR HOME MONOGRAMMING KIT.
THIS IS GONNA ALLOW
THE DO‐IT‐YOURSELF BRIDE
TO CREATE A MONOGRAMMED AISLE
RUNNER JUST LIKE THIS AT HOME
FOR A FRACTION OF THE PRICE
THAT I CHARGE IN MY STUDIO.
WE THINK THESE TWO
NEW RETAIL‐BASED OPTIONS
WILL MAKE MY BRAND MUCH MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
TO THE MORE THAN
2 MILLION BRIDES
THAT ARE MARRIED IN THE U. S.
ALONE EACH YEAR.
SO IF YOU INVEST WITH
THE ORIGINAL RUNNER COMPANY,
WE'RE GONNA MAKE MILLIONS
TOGETHER.
WHAT'S THE TOTAL SALES
FOR BOTH BUSINESSES LAST YEAR?
LAST YEAR WAS A DOWN ECONOMY,
AND WE SOLD $550,000.
ACTUALLY, BEFORE THE RECESSION,
WE WERE SELLING $800,000,
AND THIS YEAR WE'LL FINISH
ABOUT $650,000.
YOU'RE A GREAT INDICATOR
OF THE RECESSION COMING BACK.
NO, I'M A GREAT INDICATOR
OF REBUILDING MY BUSINESS
LAST YEAR BY MOVING IT
OUT OF NEW YORK CITY,
CUTTING MY RENT BY 80%,
REFORMATTING HOW I WAS PAYING
MY SALARY STRUCTURES,
AND INTRODUCING
THREE NEW LINES OF PRODUCTS.
WHAT DOES THAT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
THIS IS GONNA COST ME
$25 TO MAKE.
I'M GONNA SELL IT
TO THE RETAIL STORE FOR $37.50,
MAKING A 52% PROFIT ON IT.
THAT'S NOT THE CORRECT MARGIN.
WELL, THE MARGIN ON IT,
IT'S GONNA BE 33%‐‐
IS THE PROFIT MARGIN ON IT.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
OKAY, IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WELL, ACTUALLY, IT DEPENDS
ON WHERE YOU'RE SELLING IT.
IN STORES
LIKE LARGE CRAFT STORES,
THAT MARGIN'S ACTUALLY
REALLY COMMON. IT'S MUCH LOWER.
NO, THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH OUR SIDE OF THE BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE TO AT LEAST MAKE
A 60% MARGIN ON THAT THEN.
IF WE WERE TO ACTUALLY INVEST
MORE AND MAKE MORE OF THEM,
WE COULD DRIVE THE PRICE DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY.
IS THIS PROPRIETARY?
SOMETHING SPECIAL ABOUT THAT ONE
YOU WANNA MAKE OVER THERE?
WE MAKE THE ONLY NON‐SLIP
FABRIC RUNNERS IN THE WORLD.
AND IF YOU ACTUALLY DO NOT
WANNA HAVE PAPER OR PLASTIC,
YOU HAVE TO GO BUY FABRIC,
HAVE IT HEMMED, AND MADE.
CAN YOUR COMPETITOR MAKE
THE SAME THING?
I DON'T HAVE ANY COMPETITORS
THAT ARE DOING THAT, NO.
SO YOU'RE SAYING NOBODY ELSE
MAKES RUNNERS BUT YOU?
NOT‐‐MAKE NON‐SLIP FABRIC
RUNNERS? NO. THE ONLY COMMER‐‐
BUT CAN THEY MAKE NON‐SLIP
IF THEY WANTED TO,
AFTER THEY SEE YOU DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S SUCCESSFUL?
BECAUSE YOU DO OR DON'T HAVE
A PATENT. CAN THEY MAKE IT?
NO, YOU CAN'T PATENT FABRIC,
JUST LIKE YOU COULDN'T PATENT
CLOTHING AND YOU MADE MILLIONS.
I'M ASKING
A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
CAN SOMEBODY ELSE MAKE
A NON‐SLIP RUNNER
AFTER THEY SEE
THAT YOU ARE DOING WELL?
THEY COULD.
BUT I'M ALREADY DOING WELL.
OKAY.
I'M FIRST IN THE FIELD
AND VERY SUCCESSFUL
THAT'S ALL I'M‐‐
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING.
HOW IS THIS BUSINESS WORTH
$1.8 MILLION TODAY?
IT'S ACTUALLY WORTH
MORE THAN THAT.
I LOVE THAT ANSWER.
"IT'S WORTH MORE." OKAY.
YEAH, WELL, VALUATION CAN
ACTUALLY BE, OBVIOUSLY,
DETERMINED
IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
YOU CAN DO PROJECTED INCOMES.
YOU COULD DO CURRENT REVENUE.
IF YOU BASE IT EVEN
ON CURRENT REVENUE ALONE,
IF WE'RE MAKING $650,000
THIS YEAR, IF YOU'RE USING
A 3 TO 5 RATIO, IT FALLS
VERY NICELY IN THE $1.8.
AHA.
(mouths word)
THIS THING YOU'RE STANDING ON,
HOW MUCH WOULD IT COST ME
FOR MY WEDDING?
OKAY, UM,
SO THAT'S A HIGHER END OF OUR
LINE. THIS IS A 75‐FOOT RUNNER.
IT'S HANDPAINTED
AND HAND‐CRYSTALED
AND HAND‐GLITTERED.
THIS ONE EXACTLY AS YOU SEE HERE
WOULD BE ABOUT $750.
OKAY, SO AFTER ALL OF THAT COST,
WHAT'S YOUR MARGIN?
WHAT DID YOU MAKE ON THIS?
MY MARGIN ON THIS
IS ACTUALLY ABOUT 200%.
WOW.
MAKING $750 ON THIS,
I'M PAYING ABOUT $250
TO MAKE IT,
SO I'M MAKING ABOUT $500 ON IT.
I'M CONFUSED.
IF PEOPLE AT WEDDINGS
ARE SPENDING $750 FOR CUSTOM,
WHY A DROP DOWN
TO A $60 PRODUCT?
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
TRUTHFULLY, MY CURRENT CLIENTS
ARE SPENDING $50,000 OR MORE
ON THEIR WEDDING.
$50,000?
AND MORE. BUT THE AVERAGE
WEDDING IS $27,000,
AND THEY'RE NOT BUYING
THESE AISLE RUNNERS.
THEY CAN'T FIT IT
IN THEIR BUDGET.
JULIE, WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT A WEDDING
IS NOBODY CARES ABOUT MONEY.
THIS IS THE TIME TO HIT 'EM.
I DON'T WANNA GIVE 'EM
A CHEAP RUNNER.
I WANNA GET THE $500 TO $700
PROFIT ON EVERY WEDDING,
WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T LOOKING
AT WHAT THEY'RE SPENDING.
YOU'VE GOT A FANTASTIC BUSINESS
THAT MAKES PHENOMENAL MARGINS.
YOU'RE CAPTURING THE HIGH END.
YOU WANNA GO PLAY
IN THE TOILET BOWL WEDDING.
I DISAGREE. I WOULD NEVER
CONSIDER ANY WEDDING TO BE
A TOILET BOWL WEDDING,
AND I THINK MY BRIDES WOULD BE
HIGHLY OFFENDED
BY THAT COMMENT.
NO, NO, NO. THAT'S NOT WHAT
HE'S SAYING. THAT'S NOT WHAT
HE'S SAYING. WHAT HE'S SAYING IS
YOU DOMINATE A CATEGORY.
ADM SOMETIMES IT'S BETTER
TO BE THE BEST IN A NICHE
THAN TRY TO GO OUT AND COMPETE
WITH ALL OTHER PRODUCTS.
AND SO YOU'RE TAKING ON RISK
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE,
RISK FOR INTERNAL MANAGEMENT,
AND RISK IN THIS RETAIL MARKET.
WHY? HOW MUCH‐‐HOW MUCH‐‐
IT'S A LOST OPPORTUNITY.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY
AND I CAN ANSWER THAT.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY.
WELL, ACTUALLY, I DISAGREE
AND I CAN EXPLAIN WHY.
WELL, LET HER‐‐LET HER‐‐
LET HER ANSWER.
ACTUALLY, MOST CHURCHES
AND SYNAGOGUES
NO LONGER ALLOW AISLE RUNNERS
BECAUSE THE ONLY ONES THEY‐‐
OOH! NEW INFORMATION!
WAIT. WAIT.
BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE SEEN
THE PAPER AND PLASTIC ONES.
WHAT GENERALLY HAPPENS,
MY CLIENTS WILL REQUEST
FREE SWATCHES‐‐
WHICH WE SEND OUT
AROUND THE WORLD‐‐
AND THEY TAKE IT THERE,
AND WE GET PERMISSION.
WE'RE PERMITTED
IN LARGE CATHEDRALS
THAT ALLOW ANY OTHER
AISLE RUNNERS BUT MINE.
THE LIABILITY IS HUGE
WHY DO YOU WANNA GO RETAIL?
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
I DISAGREE.
BUT LOOK, JULIE, WHAT‐‐WHAT
THEY'RE IS, YOU HAVE A WEB SITE,
YOU HAVE ALL THIS EXCLUSIVITY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS TELL
THE CHURCHES AND SYNAGOGUES,
"GO TO THE WEB SITE." INSTEAD‐‐
BECAUSE THE CHURCHES
AREN'T BUYING THEM.
THE BRIDES ARE BUYING THEM.
THE BRIDES HAVE TO KNOW...
BUT, JULIE, I‐I‐‐
THEY EXIST, AND THE FACT IS,
ON THE INTERNET
IT'S HARD TO GET THEM
TO KNOW WE EXIST.
WELL, BUT‐‐BUT LOOK,
YOU WANNA TAKE ON
ALL THIS INCREMENTAL RISK.
LOWER MARGIN
BECAUSE IT'S RETAIL, RIGHT?
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
33% MARGINS.
WAIT TILL THE STORES
START ASKING FOR INCENTIVES...
(speaks indistinctly)
IF SHE CAN'T SEE THAT HERSELF...
(Daymond) AND YOU KNOW WHY
SHE CAN'T SEE IT?
(Mark) AND, JULIE,
YOU'RE NOT MAKING THE BEST...
(Daymond and O'Leary
speaking indistinctly)
ENOUGH!
MY GOSH!
YOU'RE WORSE THAN WOMEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I DON'T THINK
YOU NEED ANYBODY HERE.
YOU GOT TO WHERE YOU WERE
ON YOUR OWN.
I DON'T AGREE
WITH YOUR STRATEGY,
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
YOU'RE MISSING THE OBVIOUS,
JULIE.
YOU WANNA HAVE ALL THESE
RETAILERS TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOUR PRODUCTS
AND SELLING THEM.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA SELL IT
NEARLY AS WELL AS YOU CAN.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
JULIE, I WOULD RATHER HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL, PROFITABLE
$2 MILLION BUSINESS
THAN RISK EVERYTHING
TO MAYBE, MAYBE GET
TO $4 MILLION OR $5 MILLION.
I CAN'T SEE THIS SCALING
INTO A LARGE BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
TWO WORDS‐‐I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS JULIE'S
LAST CHANCE TO GET A DEAL.
LET'S GET DOWN TO BUSINESS,
ALL RIGHT?
THANK GOODNESS WE'VE MET.
HERE'S WHY‐‐
YOU NEED ME BADLY.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $250,000...
FOR 51% OF YOUR BUSINESS.
THAT'S CONTROL.
YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO
ANYTHING WITHOUT CALLING ME
'CAUSE I'M GONNA KEEP YOU
ON THE STRAIGHT AND NARROW
TO MAKE ME MONEY. BUT BECAUSE
YOU OWN 49%, YOU'LL GET RICH.
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL ME
MR. WONDERFUL.
HE'S SO APPEALING, ISN'T HE?
YOU NEED MY GUIDANCE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOTTEN LOST.
I FIND THAT REALLY INTERESTING
FOR YOU TO SAY
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
THIS BUSINESS FOR SEVEN YEARS.
I'M KNOWN AS THE AISLE GURU
AND BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT THE HECK I'M DOING.
I KNOW MY BUSINESS.
WELL, I KNOW‐‐
(Mark) EXACTLY WHAT, JULIE?
NONE OF YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRY.
BUT I KNOW HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
LOOK, JULIE, YOU'VE MET ME‐‐
THE BEST DAY OF YOUR LIFE,
OTHER THAN WHEN YOU GOT MARRIED.
BUT WE'RE GONNA GET
INTO A FINANCIAL MARRIAGE.
AND YOU'RE GONNA LOVE ME.
BELIEVE ME.
MM. LOVING YOU ALREADY. (laughs)
I'M GONNA
KEEP YOU STRAIGHT AND NARROW.
OKAY.
YOU WILL NEVER
THINK ABOUT THIS AGAIN
OR EVER DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO WALK DOWN THE PATH
OF HIGH MARGIN RUNNER,
NOT THE TOILET BOWL WEDDING. I'M
GONNA KEEP YOU OUT OF THAT MESS
BECAUSE I'M GONNA OWN 51%
OF THE BUSINESS. YES OR NO?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU'RE OUT OF YOUR MIND.
WHY?
TO BE FRANK, I WOULD NEVER
GIVE UP 51% OF MY BUSINESS.
YOU NEED TO GIVE UP 51%.
I ACTUALLY DON'T.
YOU NEED ME BADLY.
I TOOK AN IDEA
THAT DIDN'T EXIST,
I MADE THE WORLD KNOW
IT EXISTS.
I SHIP TO DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I'M MOVING INTO EUROPE
NEXT YEAR.
I'M THE VERA WANG
OF AISLE RUNNERS.
I DON'T NEED 51% OF MY BUSINESS
BEING TAKEN BY SOMEONE
WHO DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
THE WEDDING INDUSTRY.
I UNDERSTAND HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
THAT'S ALL
YOU HAVE TO CARE ABOUT.
SO JUST COUNTER.
I'M COUNTERING BACK AT 15%.
I'M LOOKING FOR AN INVESTMENT,
NOT A FULL INVESTED PARTNER.
YOUR BUSINESS ISN'T WORTH
$1.8 MILLION.
I THINK IT IS.
TURN AROUND, GET OUT OF HERE.
YOU, TOO.
I COULDN'T GET
A WORD IN WITH THAT WOMAN.
WOULD NEVER GIVE HER CONTROL.
SHE WOULD EAT YOU UP
AND SPIT YOU OUT
WITHOUT EVEN THINKING TWICE.
I JUST TURNED DOWN
KEVIN O'LEARY'S OFFER
BECAUSE IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
THERE WAS NO WAY
I WAS GONNA GIVE UP
51% CONTROL OF MY COMPANY
FOR $250,000
WHEN MY BUSINESS IS GONNA MAKE
$650,000 THIS YEAR.
THE MATH DIDN'T EVEN MAKE SENSE.
♪♪♪
I'M JEFF STROOPE
AND I'M FROM CABOT, ARKANSAS,
AND I'M THE CREATOR OF HyConn.
I WORK FULL‐TIME AS A CAPTAIN
IN THE FIRE BRIGADE
AND A MAINTENANCE SUPERVISOR.
(alarm blaring)
COME ON, LET'S GO! WE GOTTA GO!
(siren wailing)
ONE DAY, I WAS OPERATING
THE TRUCK, AND I REALIZED
THAT IT WAS TAKING WAY TOO LONG
TO PROVIDE WATER
TO THE FIRE SCENE.
AND AFTER THAT, I DECIDED I
NEEDED TO COME UP WITH SOME WAY
TO FIX IT, AND THEN THAT'S WHEN
HyConn WAS DEVELOPED.
I WORK ON HyConn ON THE SIDE,
ON THE WEEKEND AND THE EVENINGS.
THERE'S NOTHING OUT THERE
LIKE IT.
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FIRES
THE SAME WAY FOR 100 YEARS.
MY PRODUCT
IS GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
THE WAY YOU PROVIDE WATER
TO THE FIRE SCENE.
THE POTENTIAL HyConn
IS TO MAKE MILLIONS,
BUT MORE THAN THAT,
IT'S ABOUT SAVING LIVES,
AND THAT MEANS MORE TO ME
THAN ANYTHING.
MY PRODUCT IS READY
FOR MANUFACTURING,
AND NOW IS THE TIME
THAT I NEED A SHARK TO COME IN
AND HELP GET THE FINANCING
AVAILABLE FOR THIS PRODUCT.
I'VE INVESTED 11 YEARS
OF MY LIFE.
I CANNOT LET THIS FAIL.
AND THIS WILL SUCCEED.
♪♪♪
HELLO, MY NAME IS JEFF STROOPE.
I AM THE OWNER OF HyConn LLC.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR AN INVESTMENT OF $500,000
FOR 40% EQUITY IN MY BUSINESS.
NOW LET'S SUPPOSE FOR A MOMENT
THAT SOMEONE THAT YOU KNOW
OR LOVE
LIVED IN A HOUSE
THAT CAUGHT ON FIRE,
AND THEY COULD'VE BEEN SAVED
IF ONLY FIREMEN COULD HAVE
GOTTEN WATER TO THE STRUCTURE
JUST MOMENTS SOONER. NOW I'VE
BEEN A FIREMAN FOR 15 YEARS.
I TRIED THINKING OF WAYS
TO SAVE TIME
IN SUPPLYING WATER
TO THE FIRE SCENE
BECAUSE THERE WAS TOO MANY HOMES
AND AMERICAN DREAMS
BEING DESTROYED BY FIRE.
SO I NOW HAVE COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION‐‐HyConn.
HyConn IS
THE WORLD'S FASTEST WAY
TO CONNECT AND DISCONNECT
FROM A HYDRANT.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW THAT'S DONE.
I HAVE TWO PROFESSIONAL FIREMEN,
GONNA HELP ME DEMONSTRATE THIS.
NOW DAMON IS ON THIS SIDE,
AND HE'S GONNA HELP ME
CONNECT THE HyConn WITH
A STANDARD HOSE TO THIS SIDE.
AND KEVIN IS ON THIS SIDE TO
CONNECT JUST A STANDARD HOSE,
WHICH IS THE WAY
IT'S DONE TODAY.
OKAY, GENTLEMEN,
LET'S BEGIN NOW.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THE HyConn IS ALREADY CONNECTED.
IT'S READY
TO TURN THE WATER ON.
THE OTHER SIDE, WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO SCREW IT ON.
OKAY, NOW HE'S GOT IT TIGHT.
OKAY, NOW LET'S DISCONNECT
TO SHOW THE SPEED ON THAT.
OKAY, BEGIN.
YOU CAN SEE THE SPEED IT TAKES
TO DISCONNECT THE HyConn
VERSUS YOUR STANDARD HOSE
THAT'S BEING USED ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES TODAY.
AT A FIRE SCENE,
EVERY SECOND MATTERS.
YOUR STANDARD CONNECTIONS
CAN SOMETIMES TAKE
30 SECONDS OR MORE.
HyConn CAN BE DONE
IN LESS THAN 3 SECONDS
AND DISCONNECTED IN A SECOND.
NOW THERE'S
OVER 33,000 FIRE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
NOW THERE'S MILLIONS TO BE MADE
AT THIS MARKET ALONE.
WHO'S READY
TO MAKE MILLIONS WITH ME?
WHERE YOU FROM, JEFF?
I'M FROM ARKANSAS.
AND WHAT ABOUT YOUR
BASE DEPARTMENT WHERE YOU WORK?
WHAT‐‐ARE‐‐ARE THEY
A CUSTOMER?
THEY LOVE IT.
THEY‐‐THEY WANNA USE 'EM.
THE ONLY REASON
WE'RE NOT USING 'EM YET
IS BECAUSE ME WORKING THERE,
THEY CAN'T BUY THEM
STRAIGHT FROM ME.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA SELL THIS?
SO LET'S SAY IT WAS‐‐
WHAT, 20 SECONDS DIFFERENCE.
IT WAS AN 8‐SECOND DIFFERENCE
ON MY COUNT.
CAN I GO TO A FIRE DEPARTMENT
AND SAY,
"YOU'RE GONNA SAVE 8 SECONDS.
BUY THIS"?
DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE'S BUDGET FOR THIS?
I‐I DO.
BASICALLY, THE LAST MONTH
IS WHEN I STARTED MAKING
MY SALES CALLS.
AND OUT OF 11 DEPARTMENTS
THAT I VISITED,
I'VE HAD FOUR
THAT'S GIVEN ME HARD P. O. s.
THE OTHER SIX ARE WORKING ON
GETTING THE PAPERWORK TOGETHER
TO GIVE ME THE P. O.
WHAT DID YOU SELL THEM FOR?
THIS SIZE HERE, THE SMALLER ONE,
IS SOLD FOR, UH, $215.
THE LARGER THAT GOES
ON THE STEAMER VALVE IS $385.
(O'Leary) JEFF,
THE ONLY NEGATIVE TO YOUR STORY
IS YOU'RE SELLING
TO THE GOVERNMENT.
YOUR SECTOR'S UNDER STRESS
FOR BUDGET CUTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY.
ASSUMING THEY LIKED IT,
HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD
THAT PARTICULAR FIREHOUSE
HAVE TO PUT OUT
TO BUY ENOUGH OF THEM
TO EQUIP
THEIR TYPICAL EQUIPMENT?
MOST FIRE DEPARTMENTS,
THE WAY I'VE GOT IT FIGURED OUT,
ARE GONNA AVERAGE
ABOUT 35 UNITS.
$7,000, ROUGHLY,
IS YOUR TYPICAL SALE,
IF YOU SAID
YOU SOLD TYPICALLY 35.
SO THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
(man speaks indistinctly)
(Robert) GOING ALONG THAT LINE‐‐
NOBODY HAS BUDGET.
MM‐HMM.
ISN'T THE REAL PLAY HERE, IF YOU
COULD GET FIRE DEPARTMENTS
TO MANDATE THIS PRODUCT,
IF YOU COULD
GET MUNICIPALITIES TO SAY,
"YOU HAVE TO HAVE THIS HOSE
'CAUSE IT SAVES LIVES."
RIGHT.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE
TO GET FIRE DEPARTMENTS
TO APPROVE IT THAT WAY?
WE'RE WORKING TOWARD THAT. WE
HAVE NOT GOT THAT APPROVAL YET.
ARE THERE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS
THAT PROVIDE DIRECT PRODUCTS TO
FIRE STATIONS? LIKE THAT JACKET.
IS THERE A COMPANY
THAT DISTRIBUTES THAT DIRECTLY?
YES, THERE IS.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THEM
ABOUT THIS PRODUCT?
YES, I HAVE.
AND WHAT HAVE THEY SAID TO YOU?
I WENT INTO THEM,
TRYING TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR THEM TO BUY THE PATENT.
AFTER THEY LOOKED AT IT,
THEY SAID THAT AT PRESENT TIME,
THEY WASN'T READY TO BUY IT,
SO THEY WANTED TO HELP ME
DISTRIBUTE THEM.
THEY WANNA PUT IT
IN THEIR PRODUCT LINE.
AND HOW MUCH CAPITAL DO YOU NEED
TO GET IT INTO DISTRIBUTION?
$500,000.
I CAN'T GET OVER THE FACT
THAT THE DISTRIBUTORS
WANT YOU TO TAKE ON
THE FINANCIAL CHALLENGE
OF MAKING THE PRODUCTS,
SO THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN IT
TO THAT EXTENT.
SO I'M OUT.
I KEEP WEIGHING
THAT 8 SECONDS SAVINGS,
PITCHING A MUNICIPALITY
AGAINST SPENDING $7,000,
AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GONNA DO IT.
I'M OUT.
JEFF, I LOVE THE DESIGN.
WHY CAN'T YOU USE IT
FOR... OIL PIPELINES?
OR WHY CAN'T YOU EVEN USE IT FOR
THE‐‐THE HOSE I HAVE AT HOME?
'CAUSE I CAN NEVER SCREW IN
THAT STUPID HOSE AT HOME.
RIGHT. LIKE THAT ONE?
WHY'D YOU WAIT SO LONG
TO SHOW US THAT?
YEAH, NO KIDDING.
NOW THAT WILL BE MADE
OUT OF PLASTIC.
THIS IS PART OF THE SAME DEAL?
PART OF THE SAME THING.
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON THAT?
THAT PATENT FALLS UNDER
THE SAME THING.
HAVE YOU TRIED TO SELL THIS?
NO, I HAVEN'T.
THE MAIN REASON WHY IS BECAUSE I
BEEN FOCUSING ON THE FIRE SIDE.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LET'S STOP.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THE FIRE THING,
BUT YOU'RE REALIZING
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO CHANGE THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
NOW ON THE OTHER HAND,
THERE ARE TWO OR THREE
HOSE MAKERS IN THE U. S.
THAT SUPPLY ALL THE BIG BOXES.
THEY'RE HUGE.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU GO
TO THEM AND SAY,
"I HAVE A BETTER WAY
TO ATTACH YOUR GARDEN HOSE
TO EVERY HOME IN AMERICA"?
AND YOU CAN PAY ME 20 CENTS
AND YOU CAN MANUFACTURE
THIS YOURSELF.
THAT'S ONLY ONE CALL TO THEM.
I HAVEN'T WORKED ON IT‐‐
LIKE I SAID, I HAVEN'T WORKED ON
THE HOUSEHOLD SIDE OF IT AT ALL
OTHER THAN MAKING A SAMPLE
TO SEE IF IT WOULD FUNCTION
LIKE THAT.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU,
DON'T LISTEN TO HIM.
20 CENTS IS WAY TOO LOW.
JEFF, DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
IN YOUR POCKETS?
NO, SIR. NO, I DON'T.
(O'Leary)
LET ME SEE THAT RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
(Mark) YOU KNOW WHAT, JEFF?
I LIKE THIS SO MUCH.
WHAT IF I OFFERED YOU
$1.25 MILLION
FOR YOUR COMPANY
PLUS A 3‐YEAR
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT
AT 100K PER YEAR
TO RUN THE SHOW?
AND I'LL PAY YOU
A PERCENTAGE OF THE PROFITS
ONCE WE HIT CERTAIN HURDLES
THAT WE AGREE TO.
WAIT A SECOND. BEFORE YOU EVEN
CONSIDER THAT MADNESS...
♪♪♪
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
MARK HAS OFFERED $1.25 MILLION,
A ROYALTY,
AND AN EMPLOYMENT DEAL
FOR 100% OF HyConn.
WAIT A SECOND. BEFORE YOU EVEN
CONSIDER THAT MADNESS...
JEFF, I FIND THIS KIND OF THING
DISTASTEFUL‐‐
WATCHING A GREAT ENTREPRENEUR
BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
WAIT, HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
WAIT A SECOND.
I THINK YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS FIRE ELEMENT
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAME FROM.
I JUST WANT THE GARDEN HOSE
PIECE, ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA PAY YOU $500,000
FOR 100% OF THAT,
AND I'LL PAY YOU BACK
A ROYALTY OF 3% IN PERPETUITY.
IF WE BECOME PARTNERS,
WHICH IS WHAT THIS WOULD BE,
YOU'RE SELLING OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH US
AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE COMPANY,
AND SO WE DON'T WANT
TO GIVE THAT AWAY.
"WE"? WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT "WE"?
MY PARTNER.
HE'S MY PARTNER.
I'M NOT TAKING EVERYTHING,
HIS WHOLE LIFE FROM HIM,
LIKE YOU ARE.
I'M NOT EITHER.
I'M PAYING HIM A SALARY.
IN ARKANSAS, $100,000
IS GOING TO GO A LONG WAY.
NO, YOU'RE SUCKING THE LIFE
OUT OF HIM.
JEFF, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT MARK'S OFFER?
I WOULD WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE PERCENTAGE IS,
LONG‐TERM PERCENTAGE.
OKAY.
UH, I WOULD WANT AT LEAST
7 1/2% ROYALTIES LONG‐TERM.
I WAS GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER
ALONG THE LINE OF, UH,
MR. CUBAN, BUT THAT'S MORE
GENEROUS THAN I WAS GONNA BE,
AT $1.25 MILLION.
I WAS NOT AT $1.25 MILLION.
I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA LEAVE MY OFFER
EXACTLY THE WAY IT IS
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE TO
CHANGE IT.
IF YOU GO TO THE DARK SIDE‐‐
WHAT IS IT WITH
THIS "DARK SIDE" STUFF?
YOU'RE‐‐THIS IS
THE ENLIGHTENED SIDE.
IT‐‐IT DISTURBS ME IMMENSELY
TO WATCH YOU SUCK THE LIFE
OUT OF THIS MAN.
(Mark speaks indistinctly)
HE'S WORKED SO HARD
TO GET TO WHERE HE IS,
AND YOU'RE JUST TAKING IT
ALL AWAY FROM HIM.
THAT IS SUCH... BAHOOEY, RIGHT?
AND THAT'S THE MOST POLITE WORD
I CAN COME UP WITH.
BAHOOEY?
MY OFFER'S VERY SIMPLE.
I GIVE YOU $500,000
FOR EVERYTHING EXCEPT
THE FIRE HOSE, FOR 5%.
IT GIVES YOU THE CASH YOU NEED
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT LEAVES YOU FREE
FROM THE TYRANNY OF MR. CUBAN.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT
IT'S GONNA BE LIKE.
LET ME PUT IT
ON THE TABLE, JEFF.
$1.25 MILLION...
FOR 100% OF YOUR COMPANY‐‐
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN GREED
LIKE THAT?
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE GREED.
3‐YEAR EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT.
SO YOU'RE MAKING $100,000
PER YEAR
FOR THREE YEARS MINIMUM,
AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
WORK TOGETHER FOREVER.
PLUS... PLUS,
7 1/2% ROYALTY
ON EVERYTHING SOLD.
IF YOU ACCEPT THAT, JEFF,
I WANT A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR WHAT DIED IN HERE TODAY.
THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
100%? YOU DON'T DO 100% DEALS.
(Mark speaks indistinctly)
THAT'S CRAZY.
BETWEEN THE TWO OFFERS...
MARK, I LIKE YOUR OFFER
A LOT BETTER.
I'LL ACCEPT IT.
WHOO!
(Barbara) YES!
THIS IS ONE SMART MAN,
ONE SMART MAN.
GOOD.
(Barbara) GOOD MOVE.
ALL RIGHT, PARTNER.
LET'S GO OUT AND SAVE SOME LIVES
AND MAKE SOME MONEY.
ABSOLUTELY.
CONGRATULATIONS. GOOD JOB, GUYS.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD JOB. THANKS FOR BEING
FIREMEN. APPRECIATE IT.
ALL RIGHT!
IT'S OFFENSIVE.
MARK, IT'S OVER BETWEEN US.
HE WENT RIGHT TO THE TOP
OF THAT OFFER RANGE
IMMEDIATELY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DON'T THINK TWICE.
WHEN THIS COMPANY IS WORTH
$50 MILLION, $60 MILLION,
WE'RE NOT GONNA LOOK BACK
AND SAY, "BOY, I GAVE HIM
$1.25 MILLION. I SHOULD'VE
GIVEN HIM $1 MILLION."
YOU DON'T REALLY WANNA
NEGOTIATE ANY OF IT?
I DON'T NEED TO SAVE $50
WHEN I'M GONNA‐‐WHEN I'M LOOKING
AT MAKING $50 MILLION.
WHEN CAN WE HAVE A MEETING?
'CAUSE I HAVE A LOT OF COMPANIES
I CAN SELL YOU.
IF‐‐IF THEY'RE LIKE THAT,
I'LL BUY 'EM.
YOU KNOW, WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT
THAT SOMEONE
FROM A SMALL TOWN IN ARKANSAS
WOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
A $1.25 MILLION DEAL
WITH MARK CUBAN?
THIS IS JUST THE GREATEST.